women were generally not studied in
clinical research trials until the
mid-1990s as a consequence of that there
was a serious lack of information on the
health of women in the 1990s things
started to change and they changed
largely because the National Institutes
of Health the single largest funder of
biomedical research in the country
change their requirement that women be
considered as subjects in clinical
research but research takes a long time
and it takes a long time to begin to
include women and to study women and to
learn and it really wasn't until about
the year 2000 and in the early 2000s
that we started to see the beginning of
new research coming out about women's
health and we're still only at the
beginning of understanding what we need
to know both about women's health and
about gender differences in health and
disease we started our program women's
health research at Yale in 1998 it began
with a very generous gift from private
foundation the Donahue foundation that
was also committed to Medical Health
Research women's health research at Yale
has four major component parts the first
is our pilot project program and that
program is designed to provide
investigators with pilot money so that
they can start innovative Studies on
women's health and on gender differences
gain the feasibility data they need to
go on and apply for larger grants and
answer more definitive questions about
the health of women the second part or
second component part of women's health
research at Yale is our involvement with
the community reaching out and
partnering with the community so that we
can provide the information that people
need to know about developing findings
in research the third major component of
our work is to build our own what we
call research cores and our research
cores are really dedicated to bringing
together scientists from different
disciplines
who will work together on a particular
large problem so for example our cores
focus around topic areas like
cardiovascular health women in trauma
and women in addiction all of these
areas really have been understudied and
really need our attention and the fourth
major area of our efforts the fourth
component part of women's health
research at Yale is training the next
generation we're very committed to
helping junior faculty postdoctoral
students undergraduate students begin to
learn about how to do research and most
specifically how to include gender in
that work
once we began the program and we saw the
tremendous interest on the part of
scientists we started talking to the
community as well and we saw that people
really reached out for information about
women's health women and men but
primarily women interested in women's
health and gender differences so we also
made a big commitment to communicate our
findings to the community and doing that
really not to just tell the community
what we knew but to partner with the
community ask the community what was
needed and how they needed the kind of
information from us that we had we're
interested in engaging the community in
a whole variety of ways we offer a
newsletter that goes out quarterly we
have a wonderful website and invite
people to our website we also are
involved now in social media so people
can contact us through Facebook or
Twitter but we want to reach out in
various ways that are comfortable and
familiar to people of all different ages
no matter where they are in the country
and even outside the country because our
reaches not only become national but has
begun to become international as well
the program is funded by the grants that
we receive as well as through an annual
appeal which really is tremendously
important to us in covering our
operating costs every year in addition
to that we're very interested in
building our endowment we have already
begun in that regard and are very
excited about seeing that as a source of
revenue over time so a program that
really directs our focus on women's
health and on gender differences exists
in perpetuity